we'll take it off at some point
all right jd jd where'd you grow up
where are you from originally originally
from roman mountain tennessee
and uh did you have the clan growing up
in your family as a kid yeah
somewhat on my grandparents side
how did you get involved well
around 2015 or so when dylan roof
he's took and shot to black people in
charleston and that
church you know and uh ever p every
picture that i saw
on tv of him he was having the
confederate flag in his hand
and he never was a member of any
organization
you know and uh then they go and take
the flag down
in south carolina off to the state
capitol building
because of that and i i thought you know
that was kind of a slap in the face to
the
to the south our ancestors that fought
in the civil war
i had people on both sides of my family
that fought in the civil war for
tennessee and north carolina
and uh in 2017
i joined the loyal white knights and uh
i just wanted to get out and try to make
you know
do my part and uh
try to make a difference i mean
like iw was saying if we don't pull
together you know it's going to be like
a sinking ship
our rights are going down the drain
every day
and i just wish my grandparents was
around to see me and know that i'm
doing my share and trying to preserve
our history
and uh i don't consider
myself really as a racist i mean i'm
more of a
separatist i believe in keeping the
races separate
that's what god intended that's why he
put us on different bodies of land
different english you know language
just different cultures all together and
i believe that the white race is a
superior race
and uh that's just uh
that's kind of the way i feel about it
what do you wish the united states
looked like
sure what do you wish the united states
looked like racially i mean
right now we're all very mixed yeah
we're very mixed i just wish that you
know they could
stay more to their self i mean don't
don't come and try to push them down my
throat you mean
our government and not our government
but the black race the hispanics
the you know the orientals i wish that
they would stay to their
with their cells you know and uh i think
the country would be a lot better off if
it was like that
and uh you know lincoln he freed the
slave
he was from illinois so i think they
should have given that state to the
slaves and let them all go to illinois
if that's what he pervert you know
preferred i mean i thought
right now i think it's a slippery slope
and
uh if the white people don't
get out there and try to make a
difference we're gonna
we're gonna give our history our
heritage away i mean it's gone
but you know it's i just wish that more
more people would see the light and see
where this country's heading
because i give it another 10 years we
will not be able to do what we're doing
today i mean
it's going to probably be a felony to be
seen in the clan road
i mean it's just a matter of time
what is the clan's biggest issues today
is it immigration
well we uh we're strongly against uh
race mixing the mixed race you know
mixing races uh messing with our
monuments our flag our history
especially in the south because we were
originated in the south in pulaski
tennessee
and uh being from tennessee you know the
clan's always been
strong in that state and in north
carolina
and uh i just wish that uh
you know we we had a better
opportunity to get out there and make a
difference
because they they're not they're not
wanting to issue
us permits stuff like that to have
rallies or anything
or public demonstrations but you've got
all these protests
and stuff going on and they're they're
just out here
doing what they want to do and tearing
up the country and
nothing's said i mean it's not the clan
i mean there's a lot of these other
groups i mean they're
they're not doing that
are you a religious person yes sir the
klan is a religious organization yes sir
what what aspects is christianity that
is the basis of the clan
well i'm southern baptist okay i'm
basically baptist
i mean there's methodists presbyterians
you know no catholics i mean
and you are a imperial wizard or
granddaughter i'm a grand dragon i'm
over north carolina and south carolina
what are you doing okay and what is it
what is the grand dragon
it's the state officer i'm over the
state
and uh i'm right under the imperial
wizard
you know
so what is it about african americans
that
you want them to be separate well i
don't think god intended for them to
be mingling with us and especially
breeding with the white race
i mean it it brings about a mongrel race
i mean a mulatto color i mean nothing
makes me any sicker than to see a little
kid running around in their skins just
gala
i mean you know i'm a lot too color
i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't feel so bad
about the blacks
if our government wasn't pushing them
down our throat
just like in the 60s i mean they they
pushed them down their throat and the
schools and
you know cafes restaurants i mean
i mean it's just something that i don't
think should have ever happened was the
clan changed
i mean you've only been a member for a
few years but i've been
yeah several years but uh
the clans really changed a lot we're not
as violent
as it used to be you know back in the
60s they was about
some violet clan groups especially in
mississippi
and uh it gave the clan a bad rep
but uh today we're more
i want to say laid back and uh
it's not a more of a terrorist group
than what they used to be they claim
that we're
in between the nazis and al-qaeda we're
ranked number two in the
in the world as one of the worst
terrorist groups
i don't see how they could rank us up
there you know like al qaeda
or the nazis i mean we don't
we don't go out and just kill people you
know
have you traveled to other countries no
i don't i've never been in another
country but i've been all around the
southern states
i've not lost nothing up north i'm not
going up there
so what do you think about the state of
of our country and its future
right now i think it's it's
going to eventually end up in turmoil
and uh
donald trump he talked a good talk at
first that got him into
that got him into office and uh
you'd be voting for trump yeah i'll vote
for trump i did the first time
i will this time you know i hope he's
got a chance
i mean uh i've never known a president
to go into office and
so many of his own party be so
much against him you know and uh
wouldn't wouldn't let him do what he you
know what he said he was going to do
like i said he talked a good talk that's
what put him in there
but uh if he's if he gets in there again
the next go around i hope that he can go
ahead and
and do what he set out to do especially
with the border wall
we've got a bad problem with immigration
you know
and dealing with china i think that was
one of the worst things we've ever done
was passed a
nafta bill that free trade agreement
because it took
a lot of our textile workers our jobs
away from the textile workers send it to
china mexico
and you can't even go to a store and buy
anything that's not made in china taiwan
mexico
especially clothes i mean i remember
rocky boots and stuff i was you know
i hunt a lot and i always tried to have
a good pair of insulated boots and
even rocky boot company they're made in
china now
i mean they need to we need a president
that will bring our jobs back and i
think the country would be better off
and give the people here
the opportunity to go back to work i
mean
if they would stop the immigrants from
coming in here that would make a
you know a big difference if you know
finish that border wall
i mean i'm all for that
did you have children no sorry no kids
you're married
no sir what are you proudest of in your
life
sorry what are you proudest of in your
life what am i proud of
well i'm proud that i'm white that's one
of the main things i'm proud of and
i'm pl i'm proud that i come from the
family i came from with the background
and that i've got ancestors that fought
in the civil war for the south i mean
everybody says that slavery was the main
issue in the civil war it could have
been part
but uh myself i think it was over mainly
over the money
and states rights you know we had the
the cotton the tobacco all the
agriculture down here
and uh taxes you know they probably
wasn't paying the taxes on their stuff
you know
and uh but you know that's
i mean if i can make a dollar and get by
with it i'm gonna do it
i mean they knew that once they uh
pulled from the union when the southern
states succeeded
that that's what they were succeeding
over
the taxes states rights and
i'm not going to leave slavery out i'm
sure slavery had a part to do with it
but the north had slaves i mean we got a
lot of our
slaves from the north even our
presidents
grant when when he became president
he didn't give up his slaves until he
got nominated
to be a president i mean then he gave
his slaves up what four or five years
after the civil war
i mean i mean they just
they tell just like robert e lee said
the victors of war will write the story
and i remember growing up in school all
the books that we studied
in school was published from up north
they wasn't none of the books published
from down here
they tell you what they want you to
learn and that's why the people today
they don't know their history i mean if
the blacks had any clue
and if they had had enough sense that my
book and study history
they wouldn't be going out here and
voting these democrat tickets because
the klan
was founded by democrats a republican
freedom
but they're so much against the
republican party
the party that freed them you know i
mean it's got a lot to do with the
history
and they're not teaching it in the
school and that's what our younger
generation is going to grow up to see
a bunch of lies i mean that's my opinion
i'll go to my grave feeling that way
and i mean it's it's a shame what uh
what we're going to leave the the kids
for the future i mean
the shape it's going to be in this
country's uh
i see every day it's getting worse and
worse i mean
were there ever lynchings in the clan
well i'm sure they were years ago i mean
they've not been no lynches in probably
almost say
50 60 years but most of the lynchings
were more down south
like i said a lot of the other clan
groups years ago they did give us a bad
name
but as far as lynching going on today
nah i mean
you couldn't get by with it but one of
the things that's interesting about
klansmen is they're so committed to what
they believe
oh i i'm into what i believe i mean it's
an interesting standard
i got a heart of a klansman and i will
die for a clans when fighting for my
race i mean you may believe
things that other people have a hard
time swallowing but you believe what you
believe and you stand behind it exactly
yes sir i believe that god
he gave his life for our sins i believe
in god
and uh as long as i've got god on my
side i'm all right as long as i believe
that i've got
god in my heart and i i know
that there is a god you know i think
i'll be all right
but uh the blacks one thing they don't
understand about the white culture
we may have brought them over here well
not me but uh
you know years ago our ancestors brought
them over here
used them for slaves but you think about
it we brought them over here and taught
them how to worship god
combed their hair brushed their teeth
clothed
taught them english you know tried to
teach them right from wrong but that
didn't work
but uh they're such a primitive race
they were so used to living off the land
in africa
you know and and they should be thankful
that
that some of them were brought into the
united states
and kind of what i call domesticated
they've been domesticated and uh
you know if they don't like it i'm sure
that
we could probably use some of those big
cruise ships and send them back
i'd put in a few dollars to put fuel in
them ships
what uh so what what minorities are you
at odds with african americans mexicans
well any race that's not a aryan race
well what about the american indians we
kind of stole their country well
i know it was wrong for us to come in
and push them off their property
and do like we you know the trail of
tears that was pitiful
the way they done the indians if i'm
going to have any sympathy for
any race it will be the native americans
and you know i know that but you got to
think about it too the confederates
didn't do that to the indians the north
done it
the union done it after the civil war so
if anybody's to blame you blame the
yankees
the north they're the ones that done it
have you ever had any minority friends
well yeah i have i mean
i've still got a few black guys that i
communicate
with i don't go out of my way to
communicate with them if i see them in
the store i speak
they speak to me you know they know what
i'm doing
they know who i am what i represent
they don't they've so far none of them
has ever questioned me
said anything bad i've had uh some of my
african-american friends watch some
videos on my channel of klansmen
and they've said they respect his
stand and his belief in what he believes
even though they don't agree with it
right they respect his believe it or not
man i've
i've got a couple black friends
that uh
they they care as much about their black
race as i do
the white race they don't believe in
race mixing
i mean some of them are like that they
don't believe in it
because they know it's wrong they know
the bible they know
you know why they were in africa and we
were you know in scotland ireland
you know because we're immigrants to
this country
we are we're immigrants but we've built
this country
and right now we're handing it out i
mean we're just giving it away
and you know it's a it's a slippery
slope
i'm telling you man we're kissing our uh
our heritage we're kissing it goodbye i
mean
every day you see more and more of these
monuments taken down
and street names changed and what are
they doing
they're turning right around and naming
those streets after
black people you know and
just like stone mountain georgia it's a
matter of time you know they're going to
blast that mountain they'll probably put
a monument of martin luther king on top
of it and
right now we're not even allowed to go
in there
and it's not right
all right jd well thank you for talking
with me yes sir man good luck with
everything and
all right enjoy your white power enjoy
your cross lighting tonight
yeah i will hope you attend man
you